so you probably heard that Pope Francis
reversed Catholic Church teaching on the
death penalty and now normally when you
hear things like this you hear that the
Pope reversed church teaching on this or
that subject usually it's untrue usually
the media is is sensationalizing some
personal opinion that Pope Francis
expressed on a plane when he was talking
a journalist or something like that but
in this case this time it is true or
it's true anyway that the Pope is trying
to officially reverse a teaching of the
church that has been in place for two
thousand years and that is very bad and
wrong and I would even say catastrophic
ly wrong I want to explain why there
there are two aspects to this
conversation one is about what Francis
is trying to do and whether he can do it
the other aspect is just the death
penalty itself and how Christians are
really supposed to view the issue so I
want to tackle both of these things I'm
gonna spend more time on the second
point but let's start with the first so
on the first point we should recall that
the church has taught for 2,000 years
there's always taught and men like
Aquinas and Agustin have affirmed this
has always been taught that the death
penalty is in principle permissible in
principle the state has the authority
from God to put criminals to death that
is what has always been taught even in
modern times when when Pope's like Pope
John Paul the second have had personal
objections to the death penalty still
this essential teaching has not changed
that it is in principle permissible now
that leaves a lot of room for discussion
about when and in what context and for
what reason the death penalty can be
used so there's a lot of discussion
there and as modern technology has
developed and as our prison systems have
become more advanced and more efficient
and more able to safely segregate
prisons from prisoners from society it
has been understood
many Christians and some recent Pope's
that that the death penalty is no longer
necessary in most cases in advanced
countries like our own but still in
principle it is it has always been
considered a morally acceptable act act
because because governments have that
authority that is an authority that
governments have and by the way to say
that the death penalty isn't necessary
because a country is technologically
advanced and they have advanced prison
systems well to make that argument
assumes that the sole function of
capital punishment is simply to remove
dangerous people from society in order
to protect the safety of individuals in
society now that is one view of capital
punishment but I should add it is mostly
a modern view and it is not really in
keeping with the historical Christian
understanding of capital punishment
which has said for many centuries that
capital punishment is a punishment we
call it a punishment for a reason
because it also has value as a punitive
measure and as an act of justice it is a
means for society to not only segregate
violent criminals but to speak out and
to to say that certain acts are simply
intolerable and and that's it
that's something that that can be
discussed you know we want to talk about
the reasons for capital punishment what
is the function of capital punishment
these are all areas where there can be
disagreement and discussion and debate
but the relevant point is that the the
church has never ever ever ever said
that capital punishment is absolutely
wrong it is Pope Francis who is now
after 2,000 years trying to in-state
that idea
this is not a development of doctrine
it's not what this is this is a change
he is changing it and he's not even
doing it we'll talk about this in a
minute he's not even doing it based on
development of doctrine he's basing it
on the development of society and the
change of teaching based on how society
as has developed is again catastrophic
aliy wrong now on a personal level not
that it matters how I feel personally
but the but the irony here is you know
as I am issuing I guess this defense of
capital punishment on a personal level
I've lat waffle back and forth on the
issue quite a bit I've rarely been
firmly on one side of the other but my
my personal feeling most recently has
been in for the last few years that I
oppose the death penalty in America
but I don't believe and have never
believed that the death penalty is
inherently immoral in all cases across
the world I've never believed that
so but that's just been my own and
that's just been my personal view
my personal view though has no bearing
on the moral facts of the matter
it has no bearing on what Christian
teaching has traditionally been there's
no bearing on on what the Bible says and
I recognize that my personal feelings do
not supersede any of those things
I've also admitted in the past that my
own feeling of we shouldnt have the
death penalty in America it is I admit
it is largely an emotional thing it's a
it's an emotional kind of feeling in the
gut of I don't like the idea of taking a
guy out of a prison cell and shot him
into an area a place strap it into a to
a gurney injecting poison into its veins
that is it's a I just I don't I don't
feel right about that but I recognize
the fact you know
facts don't care about your feelings
right so I recognize that
I still have the feelings but I don't
pretend that my feelings supersede
anything but I have them and it is still
as I said not inherently more
but
the Catechism now basically says that
the death penalty is inherently immoral
although it does not use the phrase
inherently immoral let's look at what
the here's what the new passage in the
Catechism says now that Pope Francis has
made his unilateral changes to it it
says recourse to the death penalty on
the part of legitimate Authority
following a fair trial was long
considered an appropriate response to
the gravity of certain crimes and an
acceptable albeit extreme means of
safeguarding the common good today
however there is listen to this an
increasing awareness that the dignity of
the person is not lost even after the
commission of very serious crimes in
addition a new understanding has emerged
of the significance of penal sanctions
imposed by the state lastly more
effective systems of the tension have
been developed which ensure the due
protection of citizens but at the same
time do not definitively deprive the
guilty of the possibility of redemption
consequently the Church teaches in light
of the gospel that the death penalty is
inadmissible because it is an attack on
the inviolability and dignity of the
person and she works with determination
for its abolition worldwide so Frances
has taken his own personal view
and he has now put it forth as the
position of the church this is his own
personal view this is his opinion this
is not what the church teaches the
church too has not taught that has never
taught that this is his opinion that he
has put into the Catechism and said the
Church teaches no that's what he teaches
that's his opinion it has not been
shared by the church it has not been
shared by most of the authoritative
voices in Christianity for 2,000 years
and I would argue it is not at all
shared by Scripture
and then he justifies the change by
quoting himself
that part at the end word says in light
of the gospel the death penalty is
inadmissible because it's an attack on
the inviolability and dignity of the
person that's in quotes and if you trace
that quote back to its origin its Pope
Francis he's quoting himself to justify
a change to church teaching and he says
now that the death penalty is
inadmissible on a worldwide scale which
to me is the exact same thing as calling
it inherently immoral I see now you and
people who are defending this or trying
to draw some distinction and saying well
just because it's admissible doesn't
mean that it's immoral give me a break
now if you tell me that it's
inadmissible in certain circumstances
then yes it doesn't mean that it's
immoral but that's already what the
church taught the church already taught
that in many circumstances in the model
world its inadmissible but that doesn't
mean that it's inadmissible across the
board that's no Pope Francis is not
saying that he's saying it's
inadmissible across the board for every
one a worldwide
so if something is inadmissible in every
case for everyone across the world
that means it's inherently immoral
because if it's not inherently immoral
then it cannot possibly be inadmissible
for everyone in every case across the
world so this is a distinction without a
difference and again I must remind you
that this idea but the death penalty is
inadmissible across the world has never
been taught by the church never been
taught and it finds little support
through the centuries for 2,000 years
the church said it was admissible and
now sits now Francis says that it isn't
and what is his reason for this change
well he says that the modern prison
system negates the need for it
that's false of course because a great
many countries do not have modern prison
systems and yet he still calls for the
abolition of the death penalty even in
those countries the prison system in
North America and Western Europe they
are not representative of the prison
systems in Africa or most of Asia or in
South Africa or Orem or I should say in
South America they do not represent what
the prison system looks like in all of
those countries they certainly do not
represent the prison system in
third-world countries that barely have
governments and so their prison systems
are are just basically a cage infested
with fleas and lice and human sewage
where you've got 20 people crammed in
and then you throw another person in and
you give them buckets of gruel or
whatever to live on and guess what the
the prince the prison systems that are
like that which are not uncommon in the
world they haven't changed for centuries
the prison system in a third-world
country is essentially the same now as
it was 500 years ago
so it is just false to claim that
technological advancements have made the
death penalty obsolete
because you can only argue that in one
portion of the world it doesn't apply to
the rest yet you have used that argument
and applied it to the entire world but
what more more to the point Francis says
incredibly that the change is made
because we moderns apparently have a
greater awareness of human dignity
we have a new understanding which has
emerged he is accusing the historical
church of having an insufficient
awareness of human dignity this is an
incredible charge and it's completely
false and it's dangerous and it's in
need of correction
that's the real problem here no matter
how you feel about the death penalty
Francis has now called into question his
own church's ability to make any moral
declarations on any subject
he is saying think about that phrase a
new understanding has emerged well first
of all III simply don't agree that the
modern world has a greater understanding
or awareness on moral issues or on the
subject of human dignity I do not see
that when I look around the world but in
terms of new understandings emerging
where are these understandings emerging
from wait where are they are they
popping out of the ground are they
falling from the sky they're growing on
trees
where is the understanding tree where
they emerged from you say oh well here's
a new understanding here's an
understanding that suddenly we all have
that nobody else had before
but but think about this justification
if if the church lacked awareness and
understanding on this essential matter
of life and death
then the question that Francis is
begging us to ask is on what other
subjects did it lack understanding and
awareness
what are the what some what other new
understandings might emerge
is Frances necks gonna tell us that
modern awareness and understanding leads
us to the conclusion that the homosexual
act isn't necessarily disordered he has
just given himself the groundwork to do
exactly that
that's what he's done
so how should we consider the death
penalty question well let's remember and
I'm not an expert I don't claim to be an
expert in fact I admit that I've I'm a
waffling you know emotional I am I am
wile and I could be emotion driven on
this subject I fully admit that which is
why I am I do not refer I'm not gonna
quote myself unlike Bo Fraser I will not
quote myself as a way to make to try to
sort through this instead I all I'm
saying is let's all look at the
information that is available to us
that's all don't take my word for it
let's look at the available information
we know we can see that God prescribes
the death penalty throughout the Old
Testament most notably in Exodus where
he says anyone who strikes a person with
a fatal blow was to be put to death in
Genesis he says whoever sheds the blood
of man by man shall his blood be shed
for God made man in his own image now
this view is pretty clearly affirmed I
think in the New Testament when st. Paul
says for for one an authority is God's
servant for your good but if you do
wrong
be afraid for rulers do not bear the
sword for no reason they are God's
servants agents of Wrath to bring
punishment on the wrongdoer how do we
imagine
what do we imagine bear the sword means
in this context
and remember st. Paul is talking is is
saying this at a time when governments
would quite literally use the sword to
punish wrongdoers
and st. Paul is I think explicitly
endorsing that how else could you
possibly interpret it he is saying that
the government is an agent of wrath to
punish wrongdoers with the sword
I think you really have to twist
yourself into a pretzel to claim that
that doesn't apply to capital punishment
not only does it apply to capital
punishment but it seems clear to me that
he is talking about capital punishment
I mean how a house doesn't need to be
phrased does he need to say by the way I
am speaking about capital punishment
no Paul is saying the government have
government has the authority from God to
use the sword as a means of punishment
not even just as a means of segregating
not as a means of societal other have
but as a means of punishment to enact
God's wrath against wrongdoing
now Jesus had a pretty good chance to
repudiate this whole notion when he was
crucified and he was hanging next to two
criminals who were also condemned to
death and one of the criminals says I
deserve this my punishment is just now
Jesus could have said no you don't
deserve it this kind of punishment is
inadmissible
but he doesn't say that in fact it is
the criminals very it is it is his
penitent acceptance of his punishment
coupled with his recognition of Christ
that leads Christ to say to him
this day you will be with me in paradise
which I think interferes with two things
it interferes with
it interferes with the argument that the
death penalty is inherently immoral it
also interferes with the argument that
the death penalty could prevent someone
from from repenting of their sins
because in this case in this very
powerful story in the Gospels it is this
criminals punishment itself which has
brought him to a recognition of the
severity of his crimes and it is that
recognition that penance that that that
repentance which then leads him on to
Christ into eternal life
so we have that we have st. Paul we have
the Word of God in the Old Testament and
and then we also have the the general
understanding and awareness of of most
authoritative voices in Christianity for
at least the first 19 19th centuries of
Christianity we have all of that all of
that together which weighs very heavily
on the side of the death penalty being
admissible I would say in fact that it
rules out the possibility that death
penalty that the death penalty is
intrinsically and more
the death penalty is if the possibility
of the death penalty of being
intrinsically immoral is ruled out then
the possibility of of making the death
penalty it admissible on a worldwide
scale is also ruled out
it is it is unavoidably playing the
death penalty in principle is admissible
and to say that it is not and to say so
on the basis of human dignity is to
accuse God the Father God the Son st.
Paul of having an insufficient
understanding of human dignity
again this doesn't mean that we have to
support the death penalty in any
particular situation but but I think it
does preclude us as Christians from
absolutely denying the legitimacy of
capital punishment as a form of
punishment
and the fact that nearly every great
Christian theologian I can think of
across the whole of Christendom
throughout history the fact that all of
them and most of the leaders of the
faith historically the fact that they
have all in Aquinas in Augusta and all
of them the fact that they have all
endorsed the moral legitimacy of the
death penalty is really like icing on
the cake at that point I mean I mean
think about it think about this year if
we can just come outside of our modern
understanding for a minute if we can if
we can release ourselves from this
modern sentimentality I think we will
see that some of all when you consider
all of the issues that Christians have
thought about over the over the over the
years think of all the issues that have
torn us apart yet even with all of that
for most of the past 2,000 years there
was very little controversy over the
death penalty there was near unanimous
agreement that it was acceptable
and our modern sentimentality of which
I am on this issue I admit plagued
still it does not change any of that it
seems that the only way for a Christian
to oppose the death penalty in principle
in every case is to say that God's word
on the subject has expired or it no
longer holds but how can we say that now
Jesus in the New Testament
does on several occasions go through a
whole list of formulas where he says you
know it has been said or you were told X
but I say unto you why but Jesus has the
authority to do that you do not I do not
the Pope does not
the Pope does not have the authority to
override God
does not have the authority to do it
even in the Catholic understanding the
Pope can defend articulate explain
matters of faith and morals he cannot
invent teachings that he cannot do Jesus
can say you were told this but this is
what I tell you and this holds now Jesus
can do that
one other pointed it to consider here
about the the human dignity argument
first traditionally the death penalty
has been supported on the basis of human
dignity that that's the basis that that
God provides in Exodus where he says or
in Genesis when he says it is because
human beings were made in my image that
if you take the life of another human
being your life must be taken so it is
it is it has traditionally been
understood that the death penalty is a
way of enforcing and kind of underlining
the human dignity by emphasizing just
how terrible and intolerable it is for
you to take somebody's life when they
are made in the image of God but second
of all I am not at all convinced that
life in prison is more humane or more
respecting of dignity than is capital
punishment now I agree that when it
comes to capital punishment and and the
issue of human dignity we have two
things taking consideration we have the
human dignity of the victim which must
be taken into consideration we also have
the human dignity of the of the of the
criminal of the guilty and they still
have human dignity human dignity is is
is not something that can be taken away
from you you can't lose it you always
have it it's part of your nature so we
have to take that into consideration we
have to respect it
but I I'm just not convinced that in
every case the best way to respect and
uphold a person's human dignity is to
keep them locked in a cage for 70 years
not convinced to them I'm especially not
convinced of it in the case of a third
world country
because there when you've got a murderer
you have three choices you can do
nothing with them and let them go into
society I think we all agree that that's
wrong you can execute them okay
or you can lock them in a cage strewn
with sewage and infested with lice where
they're gonna be you know having very
little to eat and they're gonna be
living like a dog for the rest of their
lives that's your other option there's
only three options and in a third-world
country those are your only options
I don't believe that that third option
is more in keeping with human dignity
than the second of executing I just
don't believe and even in this country
um when you have someone who has
committed the most heinous of crimes
like take a someone who was raped and
killed a child well with someone like
that
can't put them in general population
because then in that case you might as
well execute them because the prison
population will do it for you he's gonna
get beat to death in the shower or
stabbed to death in the you know in the
in the cafeteria or something so your
only other option is to keep them in
solitary confinement for their whole
lives where they're gonna be locked in a
small perhaps windowless room for 23
hours a day they'll get a few minutes of
sunlight a a week and they're gonna live
like that if you have someone who rapes
and kill a child at the age of 20 and
live say to 85 that's 65 years in those
conditions I am not convinced that that
is more in keeping with and more
respecting of his human dignity and I'm
also definitely not convinced that that
is more likely to bring him to
repentance and and thus to salvation
because when you throw somebody in in a
in a room like that and you just let
them whittle away forever I don't know
if that's going to have the same effect
as telling them listen you're going to
be executed on this day so get yourself
right with the Lord
which one is more likely to bring
someone to repentance if they're gonna
come to repentance at all which one is
more likely to to spark that within them
last thing very quickly I have heard a
few verses in the in the New Testament
trotted out to try to defend the
abolition of the death penalty and
generally people will cite three verses
they'll say he who is without sin cast
the first stone turn the other cheek and
live by the sword die by the sword
it is clear to me that these teachings
cannot and do not apply literally and
universally to the government
because if they do that would mean that
all acts of war and all acts of punitive
justice are also ruled out
because it would by that logic remove
the government's right to use physical
force at all to any end in any context
if we're supposed to I mean when it when
when the allies storm the beaches they
weren't turning the other cheek
they were let's say casting a stone even
though they themselves had sinned and
when the government locks a murderer in
prison when a judge passes that sentence
he's not turning the other cheek and he
is casting a stone metaphorically
putting someone in prison is an act of
violence
it is a act of physical force which
which the other party does not consent
to that is like the definition of
violence and not only that but more
explicit forms of violence are necessary
in order to maintain the prison and
defend it in that if somebody tried to
escape they're going to be met with
physical force so if you're telling me
that physical if you are if we're saying
the capital punishment is ruled out
because of what the government because
of what Jesus has told us about turning
the other cheek and physical force and
you're applying that to the death
penalty and applying it to the
government then I do not see how you can
apply it in that context but then not
apply it across the board and thus send
society into total anarchy
but this is not the traditional
Christian teaching nor is it what you
find in Scripture it has always been
understood and this is what st. Paul
says very explicitly that that
governments have authority which
individuals do not governments have
authority from God to do things that you
and I cannot do so the government can
take taxes from you you can't go up to
someone and take a tax you can't just go
up to someone and take money out of the
well the government can do that you
can't lock somebody in a cage the
government can do that a lot of things
government can do that you as an
individual cannot do and it has been
understood for 2,000 years that act that
execution is one of those things
now this authority that the government
has it's not absolute it can be lost it
doesn't give them carte blanche to do
whatever they want obviously the Nazi
the Nazi government had had completely
lost its divine authority because it was
serving the devil and it had completely
rejected the common good and it was
working against it and was working
solely for tyranny and evil and so it
had to be overthrown and crushed
violently and so that can happen but in
principle the government governments do
have this authority and they could
exercise it and so what Jesus is saying
here he was with sin without sin cast
the first so and turn the other cheek
live by the sword die by the sword
he is speaking to individuals he is not
telling governments how to operate I
don't see any other way to interpret
that without essentially arguing against
the government itself as an institution
all right so that is a defense of
capital punishment from someone who is
lukewarm on capital punishment there you
go thanks for watching everybody god
speed